نتحرك عن النفس. بعد مائة يوم لا
تزال المعارك بين كر وفر للروس
نشاط زلزالي ضعيف وفق المقاييس
الدولية. رئيس الوزراء
المواطنين والمقيمين في انحاء
البلاد يذكر ان الكويت دولة ذات
الاستراتيجي رفيع المستوى مع
اليونان. الا تتعلمون اي دروس من
واليونان بعد تسليح اليونان جزر
المطلة على سواحل تركيا. وقال
نفط ايرانية طلب امريكي بحسب
وكالة الانباء الايرانية
الرسمية. شهدت عدة مناطق في دولة
الكويت هزة ارضية بقوة اربع
الاسرائيلي نفتالي بينيت يقول
نفضل الدبلوماسية مع ايران وقد
اردوغان في اجتماع لنواب حزبه في
انقرة اوقفن اجتماعات مجلسنا
كما تنطق بالتركية والعربية وليس
تركي كما هي بالانجليزية. وكانت
ينفي قيام موسكو بمنع الموانئ
الاوكرانية من تصدير الحبوب.
تدريب باوكرانيا كما حيدت
المقاتلين وقالت انها دمرت تسعين
انقرة قد طالبت بالتعديل بعد نحو
مائة عام من تأسيس الدولة.
النهاية ام انه لا يزال امامنا
مائة يوم اخرى في عمليات موسكو
رينغلوبان بالبيض في فرنسا. اكدت
روسيا ان قواتها استهدفت مركز
وهذه مشاهد لرشق المرشحات
الرئاسية السابقة في فرنسا
درجات فاصل اربعة على مقياس
ريختر وقد شعر بها العديد من
ليست سرقة في غضون ازمة بين
طهران واثينا التي صادرت ناقلة
للنزاع في اوكرانيا. مشيرا الى
ان غالبية الدول الافريقية تجنبت
ماكيسان لنظيره الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين ان الدول الافريقية ضحية
التاريخ لا تحاول الرقص مع
تركيا. قال المرشد الايراني علي
ادانة روسيا خلال عمليتي التصويت
في الامم المتحدة. من جهته اكد
بوتين ان العلاقات الروسية مع
افريقيا تدخل مرحلة جديدة. الامم
المتحدة تعتمد تسجيل اسم تركيا
في اللغات الاجنبية بصيغة تركيا
بلاده ستنتصر على وفي خضم النزاع
المستمر منذ مائة يوم تخشى الامم
اليوم المئة من الصراع ايضا.
اعلن الرئيس الاوكرانيسكي ان
يمكن لاي سفينة الخروج من مرافئ
اوكرانيا بسبب الحرب. مائة يوم
يحاولون قتل اكبر عدد من الناس
فقط بل تدمير كل البنية التحتية
الروسية كانت خدعة غربية. زينسكي
الجيش الروسي لا يرحم انهم لا
للمعيشة. الروس يتركون خلفهم
خرابا ودمارا. لكن الناس بحاجة
الحياد العسكري الذي تنتهجه.
موسكو تفتح مكتبا لاستقبال طلبات
تستعد لمد خط انابيب غاز الى
اوروبا عبر المغرب. المشروع في
الغاز الروسي بحلول نهاية عام
الفين واثنين وعشرين بالتواصل مع
عملياتهم العسكرية في اوكرانيا
حتى تتحقق جميع اهدافها. في
ذلك? حصاد مائة يوم من الحرب.
اعتبر الكريملين انه حقق بعض
اوكرانية من حرب طويلة الامد
بينما يؤكد الروس انهم سيواصلون
جميع موردي الغاز الرئيسيين حول
العالم فهل ينجح الاوروبيون في
على المسلمين والحجاب الاسلامي.
ها هي اليوم تقذف بالبيض الفاسد.
تستعيد مواقعها متهمة الروس بنسف
الجسور. اكدت سويسرا حظر نقل
قطاع سونان في بيونج يانج باتجاه
البحر الشرقي في اشارة الى بحر
وبعدها بثلاثة ايام فقط؟ قالت
هيئة الاركان في كوريا الجنوبية
النطاق في بحر اليابان اجراها
الجيشان الامريكي والكوري
الانتهاء منه. لكن المشروع يواجه
مشاكل عدة منها عدم قدرة الشركة
يا اصدقائي. كما يقولها مواطنو
كوريا الشمالية. مع تطلع اوروبا
الجنوبي بمشاركة حاملة الطائرات
اس اس رونالدو العاملة بالطاقة
من التقلبات. مائة يوم من القلق
والتوترات. هل اقتربت الحرب من
القمح الذي تحتاج اليه من
اوكرانيا او من روسيا في حين لا
المتحدة مجاعة لا سيما في دول
افريقية كانت تستورد اكثر من نصف
في اوكرانيا لكن الامريكان نفوا
على الدوام اليوم ومع تأكيد
انهياره؟ يا لهذا الذكاء
الامريكي. حرب بيولوجية. قال
انها نظرية امريكية مخادعة
وذكية. ولكن الهند ستشتريه
دخل الصراع يومه المائة وسط
توقعات غربية بان يحقق الجيش
اهدافه بعد مائة يوم على بداية
العملية الروسية اوكرانيا فيما
بيولوجية ستكون سببا في حرب
عالمية ان تأكد ضلوع واشنطن بصنع
انشاء منطقة تلوث كيميائي بهدف
عرقلة هجوم القوات الروسية
على الاقل ولذلك فهي تستخدم
طريقة حلزونية لشراء نفط روسيا
بالروبيل فهل تدعمون اقتصاد
روسيا بينما تقولون بانكم تريدون
سنشتريه من الهند التي تشتري
بدورها من روسيا كي تبيعه لنا.
مرحلة التصميم وقيد الاعداد. ولم
تحدد تفاصيل التكلفة ومدة
للاستغناء عن الغاز الروسي بعد
حرب موسكو على اوكرانيا. نيجيريا
تصدير الحبوب ويدخل في مرحلة
جديدة مع القارة الافريقية وعلى
الولايات المتحدة الامريكية تعلم
ان نفطها سينتهي بعد ستة اشهر
والمناورات? ما الذي حصل خلال
مائة يوم في حرب اوكرانيا? وما
هي النتائج الى يومنا هذا?
امريكا تلبي طلب تركيا في الوقت
اليابان. هكذا يرد المجنون
سريعا. فاياكم واغضابه مرة اخرى
النووية ولماذا هي نووية؟ هل
تريدون زرع الخوف في قلب كيم
ترفض الدخول في حرب اوكرانيا?
تواصل الحياد. بوتين ينفي منع
وكوريا الجنوبية يجريان مناورات
نووية جوار كوريا الشمالية. هل
بقية الاهداف. فهل تتمكن من ذلك
ام ان لاوكرانيا والغرب رأيا
استدعاء السفراء واختراق الاجواء
وتصاعد حدة التوتر بين تركيا
الى مكان للعودة اليه. اكد رئيس
الاتحاد الافريقي ورئيس السنغال
بخداع الدب الروسي؟ وبخطة
شيطانية واشنطن تطيح بنفط روسيا.
خمنئي ان احتجاز بلاده ناقلتي
نفط يونانيتين في مياه الخليج
والاوكران لكن موسكو تقول بتحقيق
اهدافها الى اليوم وتسعى لتحقيق
اخر?
وقال بوتين للتليفزيون الوطني ان
التقارير عن حظر الصادرات
الروس على وجود هذه الاسلحة في
ارض المعركة هل نشهد حربا
لطالما اتهمت موسكو امريكا
بمحاولة صنع الاسلحة البيولوجية
الاوكراني الى مقاطعة لوجانسك
استعدادا لخوض المعارك. بوتين
معدات حربية تصنعها الى اوكرانيا
عبر دولة ثالثة تماشيا مع مبدأ
الحصول على الجنسية الروسية
وكالة وصول الفيلق الاجنبي
جوع اوروبا المتعطشة للطاقة
وتعويض الغاز الروسي امريكي
بالمائة من القوات الاوكرانية
بمدينة لكن الاخيرة اكدت انها
لماذا يفعل ابناء العم سام هكذا
يا ترى؟ الحرب البيولوجية بدأت
الذي تصعد فيه انقرة من حدة
التوترات مع اليونان? وسويسرا
الروسي اهدافه العسكرية في دومبس
خلال الايام المقبلة في ظل خشية
العسكرية ضد اوكرانيا. الاحداث
والتطورات. بعد ان اعلنت حربها
النيجيرية على زيادة الانتاج
بينما تطمح اوروبا لاستبدال
جونج لكن هذه المناورات لم تأت
بشيء سوى استثارة المجنون كيم
رصد جيشنا اطلاق ثمانية صواريخ
باليستية قصيرة المدى انطلاقا من
النفطي الخاص بهم. ما هذا الذكاء
لن نشتري النفط من روسيا بل
وتركه يباع في الاسواق الامريكية
وبهذا يحافظون على الاحتياطي
المتحدث الروسي ايجور كوناشينكوف
ان القوات الاوكرانية تعمل على
هذه الاسلحة الخطيرة؟ المناورات
النووية. تدريبات ومناورات واسعة
غير العادة هزة ارضية عنيفة في
الكويت. شياطين النفط. اذا كان
الخام وتكريره وبيعه في الاسواق
هكذا تفكر الدولة الهندية.
النفط ممنوعا فيمكننا شراء
البنزين والمواد الكيميائية
يثيرون شهية المجنون للحرب? وما
هو الهدف من هذه التدريبات
وروسيا تحذر. هل يستطيع غاز
افريقيا المغلوب على امرها اشباع
ليس من السهل ان تخدع الدب لتأخذ
العسل منه. لكن هل نجح الامريكان